clinical experts agree that we are in
the midst of an epidemic the people who
didn't live through that time really
knew very little about the origins of
the AIDS epidemic in the next day I went
to Planned Parenthood and that was where
I found out that I had HIV
[Music]
even being diagnosed with AIDS I had
full-blown AIDS when I was diagnosed in
2012 the fact that we can fully
completely recover and be I've been
undetectable for years now I'm
completely healthy it doesn't affect my
life at all whatsoever I have the same
life expectancy as anyone else I'm on
disagree because I feel like it's what
you make it and also there's people
across the world that don't have those
resources or they're getting killed so I
feel like not everyone can just go to
the LGBT Center or go to the doctor and
get taken care of so that's why I'm I
disagree
like good example are my parents I was
very nervous in telling them when I
received this diagnosis they didn't know
how to handle it how does to take care
of me or proceed or how to even support
me there are things that changed and
then as time passed by they finally
started getting more familiar with it
they they've come to accept it in a
short amount of time for me like I don't
think I ever have relationships that get
beyond the point of once you know we're
gonna either go forward as a friend or a
relationship or we're not I mean the
last time I remember that I was 17 and I
had a buddy of mine we're at the movie
theaters and there was like some gum or
something and he was just jokingly like
oh be careful you don't want to touch
that you'll get AIDS and I totally took
that moment to tell him and to open up
and he changed and it was it was just a
joke in his mind and I knew it was just
a joke so I took that time to be like
look this is what it means this is why
it's not necessarily so funny in this
context and he apologized and we grew
and we're still friends till this day
yeah I don't think anyone's treated me
like unfair dreaming different well they
treated me differently because I try to
like victimize myself or like they'll
make comments like oh like how do you do
it like how are you thriving how are you
surviving and I just I think people just
like used to always feel sorry for me
and I kind of didn't like that so I was
like you know I just never wanted to be
a victim and that's why I go so hard
today with my whole career and
everything that I do
[Music]
when I lived in Orange County I was
volunteering for a nonprofit that
specifically targeted 18 to 24 year old
men around sti's and avoiding getting
HIV so I thought I was gonna be the last
person to get HIV the fact that I was
diagnosed with AIDS and thought I was
gonna be dead in three years told me
like I didn't even know that I could
live with HIV I mean I was born positive
so when I found out I was 11 I found out
because my doctor let it slip and my mom
had to tell me because I wasn't she felt
that wasn't of age yet the next week and
in school we were taking sex education
we were learning and I had found out all
about this HIV and the death rates and
what it meant to be positive and I'm
this 11 year old so I it is this thing I
definitely I weren't it was a crash
course I'd say I learned fast about what
everything was but for me I didn't even
get to that point yet and the school
systems in America I feel like aren't
out here really teaching everyone about
like same sex in our course and like
they only teach like normal in our
course our normal even the emotional and
mental state of it right it's not even
that's not even we're not even there
yeah that's that gorgeous thing we
should be talking about how to handle it
on an emotional level on a mental level
you know and like I have have had
clients who have been at gay pride and
then they go into a booth to go get
tested and then you go and you come out
and you have HIV and now you're supposed
to go and have fun at pride and nobody
told you that's funny about you
mentioned that you go to a testing booth
and then you found out in your out pride
because that's exactly how I found out
and when I did they did offer me
services like kind of right then and
there but it also was just like very
overwhelming because I just started
because I wanted a prize and I walk into
a booth right and I walked out and then
it was just like oh my goodness like my
whole entire
just like kind of changed like that
[Music]
I am Not Afraid to have children because
we have the stats of how many women have
not passed the virus to their children
having a natural birth since then since
its 14 years now we've only progressed
with the medication and now in the last
four years we've come you equals you
undetectable equals untranslatable and
we knew if you couldn't pass your baby
14 years ago pass HIV to your baby
that rate there said that u equals you
was a fee we just couldn't prove it
until we had case study after case study
with eighty thousand people you know two
different times to be able to
scientifically say undetectable equals
untranslatable you don't pass it today
and if you take medicine you're good so
I know for sure you know I could yeah I
can have a child then they won't be HIV
positive but I'm still to this day
dealing with that little extra of what
if and letting that stop me and letting
that be the the thing I still have to
overcome so when we were asked the
question for some reason my mind was
solely basing it on oh my god what if I
get a kid now like I'm totally not ready
for it but basing it on the whole HIV
situation I would have to walk over just
want strong leader
I'm not afraid to have children because
I have my diagnosis
[Music]
you know what I I wasn't I wasn't
necessarily taking preventive preventive
measures in my younger years I would
just wing it all the time and whenever I
would get tested I would always say oh
great I dodged a bullet but looking back
from now I would say that it's the
result of my past actions I feel like I
also agree cuz I kind of knew what I was
doing obviously wasn't really the safest
thing but I had never thought especially
because I was so young I thought I was
like invincible that I would end up
being the person who got it and so I
just had always kind of told myself
while I was making the wrong decisions
oh like you'll be fine
that doesn't happen to everyone like
you'll be like lucky well I mean we were
born with it yeah there's only so much
we can yeah I will say though when I
take a step back I spent a lot of my
youth because my father passed it on to
my mom and then you know I contracted it
for a long time I put that frustration
in him and and I look at now as an adult
as a you know in my thirties where he
was when I was born and realized that
also he was in a bad place and he didn't
know what he was doing and it's not the
biggest thing I could do in my life is
give him that forgiveness and so like I
try to remind myself of that stuff as
well
okay I will speak
there was only one instance when I lied
about my status I was fairly new to the
the diagnosis and I myself was still not
fully ready to embrace it and it was
already in the heat of the moment so I
figured okay if I if I stop now then
it'll totally ruin everything I myself
am secure that I'm not going to transmit
it to my partner but I don't think we
have a time right now to educate the
partner while we're in the heat of the
moment so because I was confident enough
that I'm not going to transmit it I
simply just said oh yeah I'm I'm
negative and I can understand why
because sometimes I think about it like
what why do we even have to say it
we're undetectable there is nothing
there to pass it is impossible a blood
test cannot even pick up the level count
of the virus so it's almost like what my
adopted mom says it's HIV neutral
I agree because the way I was diagnosed
that well no one told me and I kind of
had to find out for myself and kind of
just like exploring and just I don't
know I just feel like it's just a thing
that I do and I feel like it's just good
karma for me so I leave it up to my
partner I've been in long-term
relationships where my partners were not
comfortable not wearing a condom okay
that's cool with me I've been in
long-term relationships where they're
cool not wearing a condom and that has
been most of my relationships and not
one person has contracted for me
psychologically I think growing up and
being in such denial for so long about
being gay and then being bullied about
it and like hating myself in a way for
being gay for so long I didn't lose my
virginity until I was 22 to a guy and it
was like at that point I was so so
desperate for intimacy for a connection
with another guy but the last thing I
wanted was sorry I'm getting a little
the last thing I wanted was to have a
physical barrier between us I was so
desperate to connect with another human
being so I think that's why I was
willing to compromise my body in order
to get that intimacy that I would like
desperately was
I am Lexi Gibson and I was born with HIV
I feel like my status has like brought
me to a place in my life where it
definitely over this past year has
shaped who I've become and how I carry
myself and so I feel like being ashamed
of it although I used to be it's not
like that anymore for me because it's
just something that I want to be an
advocate before and I feel like it's
just stigma looking at it now I consider
my diagnosis as like the blessing of my
life it sounds weird to say but I feel
like it was like God the universe kind
of slapping the upside of the head and
saying wake up you are on autopilot you
are living from a victim mentality and
it has led you through your course of
life to this very moment and it's time
to to change HIV is literally an
immunodeficiency like 70 other Auto
difference does it make with with with
fibromyalgia or MS you know it's it's an
immunodeficiencies you are you are not
your diagnosis there's not example who
you are you know what I mean you can be
you can you can have this you can have
that but it does not define you
[Applause]
[Music]